whale sharks are the ocean's biggest
fish but for a long time scientists
could not determine how old they could
get that is until they found evidence of
nuclear bomb detonations inside their
bodies as whale sharks age they gain
Stripes along their vertebrae kind of
like tree rings but there's been an
ongoing debate over how long each growth
band takes to form does it take 6 months
or 12 getting it wrong could mean over
or underestimating whale shark ages by a
large margin which has huge implications
for their conservation but in 1955
nuclear weapons began being tested by
detonating them in the atmosphere these
tests doubled the amount of radioactive
carbon 14 in the air which eventually
landed in the ocean and became absorbed
by marine animals these radioactive
signatures act like time stamps within
the growth bands of whale sharks and now
researchers can definitively tell that
each band takes about a year to form and
knowing that the researchers determined
that the giant sharks can live to at
least 50 years old